[Music]
when i look at a wig i see an ongoing
tradition that stretches back many
centuries which we're very proud that we
are still involved in and will continue
to be part of as long as we are needed
to
great big story is inspired by
genesis
welcome to the oldest taylors in london
founded back in 1689 for over three
centuries they have addressed the
judiciary system from ceremonial robes
to handmade wigs
i'm christopher allen and i'm courtney
ceremonial manager at eden ravenscroft
the legal profession
today dress in much the same way as they
did several hundred years ago they're a
very traditional profession and
therefore there is quite a degree of
prescription in the dress that you have
to wear when you're appearing in open
court making submissions so the judges
have to dress in certain ways depending
upon the rank of the judge and the
council appearing for them have to dress
in certain ways according to their rank
as well there are three types of legal
wigs
the barristers wig
the judge's wig
and the ceremonial full bottom wig
this would only be worn on special
occasions
wigs made on size
in the wig room downstairs a barrister's
wig will take about three weeks or so to
me for a judicial bench week which is
slightly more complicated you're looking
more like six weeks
and the ceremonial full bottom wig
is a good couple of months
wigs are made from horse hair once the
hair has been cut it's washed and
treated against any forms of disease
it's then graded by color
this ranges from very light hair to
fairly dark hair the reason being is
that a newly appointed barrister doesn't
particularly want to have a brilliant
white wig because it sets them aside as
somebody that's very inexperienced and
young within the profession and
therefore if it looks a little like it's
old at the very start
then that is the look that they
generally want to go for
once the wig is ready a newly appointed
barrister can wear it and start
appearing in court
andrew eborn qualified as a barrister
back in 1985. the reason you wear the
wig is mainly three-fold you deal with
the solemnity of the court proceedings
you deal with the tradition but most of
all it's about anonymity it's like most
uniforms people wear uniforms because
they are the great equalizer
juries shouldn't be able to distinguish
between the different advocates
appearing before them
the feeling you get when you put on the
wig for the first time is extraordinary
because it's a rite of passage it's
rather similar if you like to a knight
putting on his armor
what you're doing you're getting ready
for battle all the years of work that
went into becoming a barrister paid off
as a result of it you actually feel
ready battle ready if you like you're
getting in the mood in the right sort of
frame of mind to take on the case
[Music]
you